ausbruch aus es lager während der
türkischen offensive entkommen hunderte
es angehörige
das melden syrische kurden kramp
karrenbauer kämpferisch bei ihrem
auftritt vor der jungen union geht es
auch um die kanzlerkandidatur sensation
unter dem vulkan mit einem historischen
sieg triumphieren die deutschen frodeno
und auch beim härtesten triathlon auf
hawaii
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster mit abend willkommen bei
unseren nachrichtenüberblick am sonntag
den sport hat heute lauert könig
mitgebracht in aller kürze schon gelohnt
die lage in nordsyrien wird nach dem
einmarsch der türken immer prekärer
nach tagen heftiger gefechte sind
zehntausende auf der flucht
bundeskanzlerin merkel forderte
ministerpräsident erdogan telefonisch
auf die militäroffensive gegen die
kurden sofort zu stoppen
doch die türkischen truppen rücken
weiter gegen die kurdischen einheiten
vor
derzeit vor allem in der grenzstadt tel
aviv etwa 30 kilometer entfernt sollen
während der kämpfe fast 800 unterstützer
der terror miliz es aus einem von kurden
bewachten lager entkommen sein glück
weil dort berichtet mehr als 80.000
familienangehörige und unterstützer von
es terroristen sind in vier lagern im
kurdisch kontrollierten nordsyrien
interniert darunter viele europäische
staatsangehörige mehrere hundert nutzten
nach syrischen angaben die kämpfer heute
um aus dem lager eines zu fliehen
die bewache würden zunehmend abgezogen
um den türkischen angriff abzuwehren
sagte ein kurdischer kommandant wir
haben unter großen opfern dieses gebiet
in den letzten jahren zum sichersten in
ganz syrien gemacht und wir waren nie
eine gefahr für die türkei haben nicht
eine kugel auf die türkei abgefeuert die
türkische armee und die mit ihr
verbündeten arabischen freischärler
rückten heute weiter nach syrien vor
sie besetzten nach eigenen angaben die
grenzstadt tel aviv
dabei kam es auch zu heftigen kämpfen
mit kurdischen kräften
die usa kündigten unterdessen den
rückzug von bis zu 1000 soldaten aus der
region an das sehr klug so präsident
trump nicht in die heftigen kämpfe an
der grenze verwickelt zu sein
die kurden ziehen am sagte er das ist
gut
nach internet berichten sollen die
arabischen kämpfer auch eine syrisch
kurdische politikerin bei einer
straßensperre südlich von cala blatt
brutal hingerichtet haben bei einem
türkischen luftangriff wurde nach
angaben einer französischen journalistin
eine zivile wagenkolonnen
mit medien arbeitern angegriffen
mindestens zehn menschen starben
ihr auftritt wurde mit spannung erwartet
nach viel kritik hat sich die
cdu-vorsitzende kramp-karrenbauer der
jungen union präsentiert beim
deutschlandtag stand nicht zuletzt die
frage im raum kann hkk auch kanzlerin
ihre möglichen konkurrenten
ex-fraktionschef märz
gesundheitsminister sparen und
nrw-ministerpräsident laschet hatten
dort zuvor aufgetrumpft außer brücken
mathis feldhoff
der empfang ist freundlich fast herzlich
aber es ist ein besonderer auftritt für
die cdu vorsitzende
ein besonders schwieriger seit wochen
ist sie unter druck gerade aus der
jungen union in ihre heimat saarbrücken
wird sie heute um verlorenes vertrauen
lasten streiten aber lasst uns nie
vergessen der politische gegner sitzt
immer außerhalb unserer reihen nie
innerhalb sie lobt die eu für ihre
klimapolitik und greift die afg scharf
an dass die jungpolitiker auch eine
urwahl des kanzlerkandidaten beschlossen
haben erwähnt sie nicht als wolle sie
die attacke auf ihre person einfach
ignorieren so wirkt der deutschland tag
wie ein schaulaufen armin laschet der
ministerpräsident aus nrw und jens spahn
der gesundheitsminister hatte umjubelte
auftritte und friedrich merz bei dem
jede äußerung wie eine bewerbung wird
auch wenn er nur der j seine
unterstützung zugesagt wenn sie wollen
dass ich dabei bin dann bin ich dabei
die junge union hat es verdient dass wir
uns alle dafür wirklich nach kräften
einsetzen dass vielen usern reicht der
auftritt von ak nicht ihre pannenserie
ist nicht vergessen
der junge union ist die stimmung
schlecht und die rede war natürlich ja
sie war gut
absolut aber das reicht nicht aus ich
denke gerne redet kann mir alles
rausreißen
wir müssen schon taten kramp karrenbauer
hat heute gezeigt dass sie kämpfen will
auch eine kandidatur als kanzler gegen
rassismus und antisemitismus in berlin
sind heute tausende auf die straße
gegangen
zu der demonstration aufgerufen hatte
die organisation unteilbar als reaktion
auf den antisemitischen anschlag von
halle am mittwoch hatte ein
schwerbewaffneter rechtsextremist vor
der synagoge und in einem döner-imbiss
zwei menschen erschossen
polen wählt ein neues parlament die
große frage wie stark wird die
regierende partei
letzte umfragen sehen die
nationalkonservativen mit ihrem chef
jahres matschinsky deutlich vorne
seine partei hatte unter anderem mit dem
umbau des justizsystems kritik ausgelöst
und 30 millionen menschen sind noch bis
21 uhr aufgerufen ihre stimme abzugeben
offenbar war und ist die wahlbeteiligung
diesmal sehr hoch natürlich steger in
warschau was bzw wer hat die wähler denn
diesmal hauptsächlich motivieren können
nun diese wahl wird wirklich hoch
emotional diskutiert in polen
sie wird als richtungswahl gesehen als
referendum für oder gegen kaczynski also
für oder gegen seine partei die große
frage ist wer konnte wirklich seine
wähler mobilisieren
im süden und osten wurde
überdurchschnittlich gewählt dass das
süden osten das klassische kern land der
pis aber auch ihren war schauen um den
liberaleren städten und regionen sind
die menschen überdurchschnittlich wählen
gegangen und jetzt muss man einfach mal
abwarten wie hoch der sieg der kies
ausfällt wird wirklich wieder für eine
absolute mehrheit reichen
das ist die spannende frage wieder
absolute mehrheit und dann vielleicht
ein munteres weiter so in kurzer zeit
wissen wir wer mehr vielen dank natalie
steger
japan kämpft mit den folgen des taifuns
megi bis 33 menschen oder ist der
wirbelsturm in den tod 19 gelten noch
als vermisst
ergebnis war gestern südwestlich von
tokio auf land getroffen
starker regen hatte ganze
und statt gebiete überschwemmt dutzende
erdrutsche ließen häuser einstürzen
heute schwächte sich der taifun über dem
meer wieder ab während an land weiter
nach überlebenden gesucht wird wir sind
beim sport und einem historischen
triathlon wettkampf auf hawaii arbeit
zum ersten mal holen sich zwei deutsche
den siegerkranz für jan frodeno ist es
bereits der dritte titel bei der
ironman-weltmeisterschaft anne haug
schafft die premiere und holte als erste
deutsche frau den titel
nach sieben stunden 51 minuten und 13
sekunden überquerte jan frodeno die
ziellinie so schnell wie noch kein
anderer athlet beim härtesten triathlon
der welt ich habe glaube ich noch nie
als ein rennen so sehr leiden müssen und
genießen kann
bei den frauen führt lange die britin
lucy charles barkley das feld an
doch mit einer sensationellen lauf
leistung zieht anne haug noch an ihr
vorbei der überraschungs triumph nach
acht stunden 40 minuten und zehn
sekunden
[Gelächter]
riesig nicht nur die freude sondern auch
die leistung der deutschen auf big
island titel verpasst aber kräftig
gepunktet auf dem weg zur tennis-wm
alexander zverev verliert das finale von
shanghai gegen den russen daniil mit
werden nach ausgeglichenem ersten satz
läuft beim deutschen nicht mehr viel
zusammen der russe mit berdijew mit
einem ass zum 6 4 und 6 2 1
zverev dennoch mit guten chancen beim
saisonabschluss turnier in london seinen
weltmeistertitel verteidigen zu dürfen
daumen hoch für sebastian vettel als
zweitschnellste des formel 1 grand prix
in suzuka den konstrukteurs titel holt
sich vorzeitig die konkurrenz von
mercedes
es war absehbar zu groß war die dominanz
der silberpfeile auch heute wieder
valtteri bottas erobert aus der zweiten
reihe die spitze sebastian vettel
verliert einen platz ist zweiter
mercedes holt gegen ende den in führung
liegenden hamilton überraschend zum
zweiten stopp statin durchfahren zu
lassen
dadurch kommt vettel rechts wieder auf
rang zwei walter roboters wird mit dem
sechsten grand prix sieg belohnt eine
runde zu früh systemfehler der
rennleitung
lewis hamilton kann schon im nächsten
rennen seine sechste fahrer titel
gewinnen und vettel bleibt erstmal bei 4
dank norwich und uns bleibt noch der
ausblick aufs wetter im norden bei 15
bis 20 grad teils dichte wolken und
etwas regen sonst gibt es viel sonne und
es ist 21 bis 26 grad warm
die weiteren aussichten bis dienstag
bleibt es noch sehr warm
danach wird es wieder kühler so viel von
uns für den moment claus kleber freut
sich um 21 uhr 45 mit dem heute journal
auf sie und wir sind dann morgen abend
wieder zur stelle um sie wir wünschen
ihnen noch einen schönen sonntag